everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm before we get into today's
video wanna let everyone know we have a
new Facebook page I'm gonna put the link
in the description below but it takes
just a minute if you wouldn't mind
liking that for me brand new page but
it's got some really great content so
thank you guys we'll go and get into the
video today we're gonna be starting our
series on the 2014 candidates tournament
one of my favorite tournament has the
top players in the entire world fighting
for a chance to play the champion Magnus
Carlsen at the end of the year each day
I'm gonna be doing coverage taking my
opinion the best game of the day or a
particular game that I just thought was
very interesting that you could learn a
lot from today's game is gonna be
featuring two of the top players we have
Vichy and nods gonna be playing the
white pieces an on obviously the player
that was the previous world champion
just lost to an on a few months ago and
his opponent playing the black pieces is
Levon Aronian the number two ranked
player behind Magnus Carlsen in the
world the favorite by a lot of people to
win this tournament my favorite actually
to win the tournament I think he's just
the best player in the field right now
so definitely going to be interesting
another reason that I wanted to do this
particularly is because there's the anti
martial in this opening I made an anti
or I actually made a martial video
attack video not too long ago so I
thought it was pretty cool that I make a
video and then a couple weeks later we
have the top pros actually playing that
so it gives a little more insight into
what we're doing so we go ahead and get
started the Marshall attack starts out
and the RAI loop has closed we have E 4
E 5 9 f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 again
this is the right Lopez kicking the
bishop back Knight to f6 Castle Bishop
here to e7 getting ready to castle on
the kingside the rook swinging over
weakness here on e4 pawn to b5 pushing
the bishop back and the King coming back
here and then white having to decide
what he wants to do now on the marshal
attack we have pawn to c3 and then the
palm pushing forward to d5 this is the
attack from black White has a few
options one would be to attack on the
Queen side with pawn to a4 this is one
way to play the anti Marshall it's
but it does get pretty tricky black can
now respond with pawn to b4 this
threatens a lot of the squares that the
knight would like to come to Knight to
a3 Knight to c3 gets a little cramped
for whites another option that we have
is exactly what a non played he played
pond here to h3 somewhat of a waiting
move recognizing his opponent's going to
be playing pawn here to d5 but it does
allow him a little bit more room than
playing the pawn here to c3 black
responds with Bishop here to b7 getting
ready to attack the center of the board
we now see pawn to d3
since this light Bishop has come outside
the pawn chain it's come over here
controlling this long diagonal it's now
okay to play pawn to d3 can solidify
this pawn chain open up the door for the
bishop to get out if he wants to also
has another way for this knight to come
on board if he wants to so a lot of
different options by playing this pawn
here to d3 black pushes forward as we
talked about with pawn to d5 this is
kind of the goal for black to give up
some material early on into the game so
you can control the center give white a
very cramped position and then try to
find some weakness in White's position
so White's going to capture Mike's gonna
recapture and now White has the
opportunity now to go ahead and take
this pawn because he has two attackers
his Knight and his rook here on e 1
white decides to kind of lay that in
first play Knight to d2 which is
somewhat interesting black now has a few
more options he could play Knight to f4
definitely a possibility he decides in
this particular game to play Queen to d7
what's interesting it does complete his
development so that's good but it does
still again leave this pawn here on e5
and it has a somewhat awkwardly placed
Knight here still on d5 so the Knights
gonna take on e5 as we talked about and
then after the other night takes that
we're gonna have the rook swing up here
and take on e5 and black is now up or
excuse me blacking out down and material
now we're gonna have the knight swing
back here to f6 and then we have the
rook coming back here to e1 so if we
kind of analyze this position from both
sides it's kind of what we talked about
before
why does up material he's one central
pawn up but White has a very cramped
position on this board it's very
difficult for him to get many of his
pieces developed this rook here on a
one's not gonna be doing anything for a
long time
this dark-squared bishop is not gonna be
moving anywhere great this Knights even
somewhat awkwardly placed doesn't really
want to come here to a c4 or even e4 so
gonna be looking to come to f3 if it
goes anywhere and then this dark square
Bishop can get involved this Queen is
not very centralized it's not doing too
much this rooks just kind of hanging out
here it is controlling this long e-file
but again it needs to be a little bit
more active again from black side very
active position both the bishops
controlling along diagonals we have the
Queen very centralized the rooks are
already connected so we can swing those
over to this opened e-file or semi open
D file and open e file right here so
both sides doing exactly what they need
to do really all depends on if Levon
Aronian can actually find a weakness and
vision on the fence or efficient on can
kind of hold on to that material and
then find a weakness and Aronian set up
later on in seize control black now
swings his rook over to e8 again giving
his big pieces of all them to the action
we now have Knight to f3 get as we
talked about trying to UNCHR amp the
position that white has on board now we
have Bishop here to d6 more centralizing
than before also opening up the door for
the rook here on e8 so all very good
moves
we have Bishop to e3 again developing
trying to make sure that white can
continue his development definitely
wants to have more of a centralized
bishop right here
then we have rook to e7 getting ready to
swing his rook over to e8
double-barreling here on the e-file is
gonna be good for the rooks then we have
the pawn pushing forward to d4 now I had
a lot of different options he could have
played eath a3 if he wanted to he could
have played c3 if he wanted to a lot of
different options decided to go with
pawn to d4 trying to control the center
of the board
definitely no Cain move for him but
again he had a lot of different options
on that board rook swinging over to e8
as
we talked about before and then pawn to
c3 so this opens up a lot for white it
allows him a lot of different squares
for his Bishop to get to it solidifies
this pawn chain right here and it gives
him a little bit more breathing room
because he can kind of now move his
pieces around more so than he had before
Black's definitely gonna have to find
some room in here to attack or is he
gonna get into the late game and he's
gonna be down material black now plays
pawn here to h6 doesn't want to have an
awkwardly placed piece here whether it's
the bishop or probably the knight coming
over here to g5 and then we have the
Knight to e5 pretty interesting move
from an on deciding to go ahead and give
up some material doesn't want too much
of a cramped position and is he kind of
analyze this a lot of players that are
using the anti Marshall they recognize
the best way to get to an endgame and
give them an advantage and so that's
what a non I think Saul in this position
he thinks he has an advantage if he
gives back that pawn material and so
it's gonna be up to Aronian to try to
counter-attack that and somewhat get
into an endgame with the better position
so we can try to come out with a draw or
potentially a win for black so as we go
through the motions black takes after
the pawn takes the rooks now gonna come
down and take the Queen takes the knight
now takes and then we have the rook
swinging over here to d1 so as we can
see white gave up that central pawn
backing material and so both sides are
pretty good on development they both
have two minor pieces on board black has
both of his rooks here on the e-file
White has both of his rooks back here
but he can easily get him involved into
the action usually you want to have the
bishops if there's pawns on both sides
of the boards they usually play a little
bit better because they can get to both
sides of the board very quickly if you
have Knights you usually want to keep
action on one side of the board because
you can control that side of the board
very easily compared to hopping to both
sides of the board so in this position I
would give white the slight edge really
it could go either way in this position
but I would say White has these
light edge now the Knights gonna swing
over here to f6 and then we have pawn
pushing forward to c4 and White's really
looking to find a weakness in this pawn
chain over here from black black does
not want to take back here with his pawn
because the bishop can take now there's
gonna be these two stranded pawns they
don't have any pawns connected to so
it's gonna be very hard for black to
hold on to both of these pawns the rest
of the game so that's kind of what a
nun's doing he's trying to find a kink
in the armor black does not want to go
ahead and do that so instead he plays
pawn here to c6 not too many great
options that he has as far as you know
waiting to see what white does an on now
swings his rook over to here to c1 I
always want to have your rooks behind
your pawns in late-game as they push
forward and then we have the rook
swinging back over here to e7 getting
probably a little more centralized than
he wants to he still wants to kind of
double-barrel them but he does want some
safety back here with his rooks
and then pawn to a4 very very good move
from anon as he really puts Aronian to
the test as far as what he wants to do
now Aronian decides to go ahead and take
with his pawn on c4 I think this is
probably a pretty bad move he had some
other options Knight here to e4
definitely centralizing his Knight
opening up a lot of possibilities for
black again does not want to give up the
fact that he has these pawns connected
right here all of a sudden if he plays
pawn to c4 he gives up everything that
we kind of talked about so I feel like
this is definitely a bad move from black
definitely is the opportunity that anon
has been waiting for so it really just
depends on how both sides can execute
from here I'm not anon decides to go
ahead and take so again he has this a
and B pawn connected potentially here
and then black is kind of forced to just
play defense here and try to hold on to
these pawns since the pawns can't
protect themselves so then we have the
knight come over here to d5 centralized
nice little outpost the bishops gonna
swing in again more centralized
attacking the rook the rook is forced to
move then we have the palm pushed
forward
also gives a little bit of read
breathing room for whites King can also
get involved now as you approach the in
game moving away from the middle game
you actually want to use your king is
more of an offensive piece so this kind
of does two things want to attacks the
rook but also it allows for this King to
go and come to f2 III potentially and
centralized and even move down the board
if he needs to now we have the rook
swing back and then the King's gonna
come to f2 is we talked about the
bishops gonna come back here to c8
definitely wants to do more than just a
fin but again it still is on defending
duty right now the bishops gonna come
back here to f1 all this Bishop wants to
do on f1 is just stay safe and continue
to attack this pawn here on a six now
we're gonna see in the rook swing back
the Brooks now I'm gonna come to d3
again a few moves from both sides just
kind of moving around
nons kind of nicely placing his pieces
and more of attacking Aronian on the
other side just kind of moving his
pieces back and forth doesn't really
have a strong attack doesn't have any
weak pieces that an on has that he can
attack or really do much with so he's
somewhat playing defensive just kind of
moving his pieces around waiting for
vichy to make a mistake the rook swings
over here to da trying to control both
this D and E foul right here now Bishop
coming back here to e3 attacking Knight
swings back now the bishop comes back
here to be two just in case the palm
wants to push forward to a5 he's still
attacking that right there now the
knight swings back here to f6 kind of
opens up the door for the bishop to come
285 attacking both the rook but also
stopping this pawn from moving anywhere
obviously white wants to go ahead and
attack that so stopping that is very
good so great moves by vichy and on I
think going into the endgame the rook
swinging over here to e8 and then they
look here to b6 and this is again a
great move as both this rook and this
bishop here on f1 are both attacking
this pawn on a6
gonna be very very difficult for black
to hold on to this we now see the rook
come over here attacking this bishop the
bishop is forced to come back but he
does have this nice little outpost here
with his pawn here on b2
then the rooks gonna soar the Knights
gonna swing over here to the five
attacking the rook the rook is going to
be taken here on e5 and then this other
work is gonna be taken here and then the
bishop comes back here to d4
now vision actually decided to go about
gaining this material in a very long and
methodical way but along the way it did
end up proving to be very very valuable
after the knight takes here on a four
then the Brooks is gonna swing into c6
here and we see the rook swing over here
to d8 now there's a few different
options as far as what white does here
in this particular case you can kind of
pause and see what you would do I think
one of the strongest moves is pawn here
to b3 again this Knight over here on a4
is really awkwardly placed it can't go
anywhere can't come here to b6 because
it's being attacked by both of these
pieces can't come to c5 or c3 or even B
2 because of all these pieces and this
really puts it to the test right here if
then if the rook takes that's not the
biggest deal again we can now take we
can we have both of our pieces attacking
the pawn over here so we still have
options in this particular game the rook
decided to come down here to see for now
the bishops gonna come here to these six
protecting the knight now and now we
have the palm pushing forward to b3 I
think it's a move late but but all in
all it ended up working for vision on
now the bishops going to attack and the
rook swings over here now black has to
be careful he doesn't want to go ahead
and take right away if he decides to go
ahead and take with it Bishop right here
then the King can just come down on f1
and this nights going to fall it really
can't do much it doesn't matter where it
goes it's going to fall and so in a
particular game black really only had
one real move and that is a knight here
to be two white can't just take it right
away with his Bishop because now the
rooks gonna come down to d2 check go
ahead and take this bishop and actually
be able to come back in this game so
vision on after Knight here to be too
plays bishop taking here the pawn it can
take which it did this bethere game
could also if we wanted to try to get
pretty tricky play pawn to e5 forcing
this this rook here to die can't go here
to c4 or a4 it's gonna be taken by the
Knights if it stays there it's gonna be
taken by the pawn either way it's really
not that great box definitely in a
losing position black decides to go
ahead and take with this pawn now the
King's gonna come here - III protecting
the bishop after the rook check here on
e8 we see that again the King getting
involved into the action after the rook
over here the King to c3 is kind of a
dagger there's no way to stop this
Knight from dying again it was just too
awkwardly placed and so Levon Aronian
the number 2 player in the world the
favorite to win this tournament actually
goes down in the first game all three of
the other matches ended in a draw so
Vichy and on right away the player that
just gave up his title came to this
tournament hungry got a win under his
belt in the first match which again
playing as white is something that you
definitely want to do so congrats to and
on I'm excited for an amazing 2014
candidates tournament again they do have
a few days off but every day there is a
tournament I will be making a video that
night so make sure you check back also
on the website if you want to watch or
look at all the different games from
that particular day I will have that so
today I will have all four matches you
can actually see the games if you're
curious again if you haven't already
like the Facebook page the links going
to be in the description so definitely
check that out and I'll see y'all guys
in the next video thanks for watching